all right savannah
welcome back
so there's been some things going on in
your life just tell me what's going on
lately
um so lately
i
found out some news
um
i went to
the emergency room one night for
[Music]
a skin abscess on my arm
and
they before i got my paperwork back they
informed me that i was pregnant
um
yeah yeah
so i
i've got that going on
yes you do yeah
do you know who the father is
um i do you do
and is it somebody you want to have a
child with
i
or do you want to have a child even how
old are you i'm 22 22. um
it's it's
he's not a bad guy or anything like that
i won't say that it's just um
i
i'm terrified i'm just terrified of
having a a kid
i'm terrified of
the responsibility i'm terrified of
that'll be like me
and i'm terrified
that i'll have a parent like
like i had and i'm not saying i had bad
parents because i love my parents to
death you know it's just
i don't want it going through that yeah
but you're not in a situation right now
to be having children no i mean you know
like you're addicted to crack and you're
living yeah in a tent
or in your um i've been staying in my
car because they stole my tent you know
and um
i just stay in my car because i can i
can lock myself in there yeah that's not
a good situation to be raising kids
yeah
so
i um
i'm really like petrified
petrified
about what i'm gonna do
and i
i don't know right now yeah did you just
find your early on in the pregnancy yeah
um i still need to
make an appointment and kind of
talk with the doctor
more
about what's what's going on um
i need to and i need to do it rather
sooner than later
um
i've got a lot of people that want me to
have the baby and then i've got a lot of
people that
you know are like no you know
absolutely not your father is somebody
from skid row
um
he's downtown um
i met him down here right um he's not
homeless
okay
without a more stable life
you have to consider
i feel like i would be dooming
my baby
i feel like
i have nothing to offer
i mean i know you know i have people say
well you have love you know whatever
i feel mentally insane like i mean
mentally just
i can't keep it together yeah
i could see you being a great
mother at some point but just not this
point right i mean you know i
i always thought
maybe
later on in life or even when i was
sober you know
they even considered it that i mean if
it had happened then
i would have been thinking differently
but
i am
a complete mess right now you know
have you thought about
trying to get clean
yeah
yeah
i have
i'm not saying get clean because
i'm not going to say that i want to stop
using because i enjoy using i do like
i'm just keeping it honest and real like
i enjoy using
but
i'm really tired of
the chaos
the lifestyle
i'm exhausted um
you know every day getting in a
fight every day
you know
hustling you know whatever the case is
like i'm just so [ __ ] tired
and
then on top of it when i found out about
this i at least want to make a
have my mind clear when i make that
decision
you know i want to be sober when i make
the decision
but i can't prom make any promises to
anyone i i told my mom i told i told
certain people in my life i can't
make promises because right now all the
promises i make i break
i
i can't do that i don't want to get
people's hopes up that you know
i think a lot of people think that when
they found out about the baby
that oh wow you know this was this is
going to change
everything
for the better
and uh
i i wish i could think like that
but
it's not like joy hasn't set in for me
it's it's complete fear and pandemonium
in my head right now um
and i don't understand how i can be a
good mom
if i find out something like that and
then
i still do what i did you know
i still
i still hit the pipe you know like and i
i can't
i can't deal with that um
my dad loved me very much you know
and uh
every time i think about this child
i think about the day
when he looked completely heartbroken
and defeated
because he knew i wasn't going to be
enough for him to stop
i don't want that to be me
i don't want that to be with mine
i don't
and i just like
i need prayer right now because like i
just don't know what i'm doing
such a big decision yeah
and it's weird because it's like you
know
at first i told myself absolutely like i
can't have this baby you know and all
that stuff
but then it's like
i'll cry after each hit
like i'll cry or i'll
i'll
i get protective over myself now i don't
i don't try to get in fights now
i don't try to do that
because i know what's going on with me
and it's so confusing it's like i
i want the baby but i don't
i just i know how my life's been
and i can't i cannot put it through that
and i cannot trust myself enough to not
put it through and i can't do that
the foster system doesn't need one more
kid
yeah and that's the thing too like i
can't i can't give birth in and
see
a child that i can prove to you and give
it away i can't do that either
i couldn't
and
i just i mean
i never thought this would happen i just
never expected this
i guess because
my whole family i mean my dad's side
most of them are dead from addiction
my mom's side you know
she was an addict and then and then a
lot of on her side were alcoholics or
you know had issues
it's just been a mess down the tree you
know and
i can't i can't watch
i can't
risk right now
inflicting
i just don't know i'm i'm mentally all
over the place and
i i do i reached out to my mom and i
reached out to certain people that you
know i do need to get some help
just to make this decision
and know that i'm making it with a clear
mind because sometimes i don't think
clearly obviously you know i don't think
all the time
on this [ __ ] and um
i want to be a good boss
but i don't think i will be
and
the baby deserves so much better than
that
um
i can't even really get high anymore
i'm like throwing up why is that
i think from
i think my body is like rejecting it now
yeah like i'm getting sick in the
morning and i'm getting i'm gaining
weight and
i
i'm exhausted all the time and
but yeah like i've been trying i've been
trying i'll try to get high and like i
can't like i instantly get sick or
it's just it doesn't work
it's not working
nothing's like
helping
uh
i don't know
all i know is like i need a break
i know like i need a break for a few
days at least
how would you get a break for a few days
i think i'm gonna
check into the hospital if they'll take
me
put myself on a hold or something that
way
i can't leave because i don't think if
i'm not locked away somewhere
i i can't trust myself enough to not
leave a program or leave
someone's house you know i
i don't trust myself at all anymore
there's like a zero trust i have for
myself
that's definitely not a good situation
to be a mom
exactly
exactly
i just
i hope i figure it out and i hope i
i just wasn't expecting this to happen
not now
especially the life i've been living
like lately you know like it's like i
was sober
for for for years you know and
this never happened and
i surely didn't think
while i'm living such an unhealthy
lifestyle that this would happen
no and so many people are like you know
have you know like they're excited about
it they're encouraging you to have a
baby you know they like want me to have
this kid
and i wish i could be like that or feel
like that
i think
any woman would wish they could
that would be the case
but
i just
i feel like a really
i feel like
what's that word i just feel like you're
responsible
irresponsible and then i feel
i feel like something bad
it's just like something really bad
something bad would happen yeah
and i i can't tell you what but i just
feel like something bad
i don't
feel
good about any part of this i feel like
something really bad
would come out of it
and i'm not saying that that baby's bad
by no means i'm just saying
i want something good to come out of
having a baby i don't want nothing bad
happening
well it would be helpful to be in love
with the father
yeah it would be helpful to not be
addicted
yeah be helpful to not be
living in your car yeah
all those things
you know um i did try
i did try and go back to my mom's
they wouldn't let me
and
when they went
wouldn't let me i just came right back
came right back
have you ever been able to quit crack
before
i
i have always been willing
to
to stop
any substance i've ever put in my body
whether that was pills whether that was
alcohol
crystal um
you know any of those like i've never
had an issue with
eventually
being like okay like i need to stop i
need to i want to stop
this
i can't shake it
like i cannot shake it whatsoever i
it's like
uh
it it and i think a lot of times people
are like you know they don't understand
because they're like you know it's not
like um
heroin you know it's not like opiates
you know a physical
physical withdrawal from it
it's more of a mental
but i i don't think people understand
that
that's why i chase it like i do because
mentally in my mind it torments me like
i'm tormented when my mind is
going
it's the only you know it brings me
peace it brings me ease and relief
from running thoughts
of of the past
and playbacks in my mind
and i i wish i could just forget it all
sometimes like i wish i could just
not remember anything
i wish there were no memories sometimes
it's so it's it's the one thing that
i've found that's just
even though i know it's only for a
moment
even though i know it's temporary
it just takes it all away
but
it's getting harder and harder
for it to take it all away
i can't get high like i used to
i i'm chasing it continue like i'm
chasing and chasing
and then it's like i can't enjoy it
because i know what's going on with me
and i feel horrible for it i feel
absolutely horrible
i feel
yeah
i feel like a piece of [ __ ]
but
i still do it
i can sit here and tell you i feel that
way
and i feel
bad about it but then i still go and do
it
and that's just that's the main reason
why like i i just don't
that tells me a lot right there
because i do when i think about
i do have some form of
love
for
child but i
i can't stop being selfish
i'm certain one day you'll be a great
mom
i just don't know if right now is the
time
and you're so young too so
yeah yeah plenty of time
yeah so
um
i need prayers and
a lot of them
i just hope i can get my [ __ ] together
honestly
i really hope so
all right savannah thank you for coming
in
latest news
you'll figure it all out you're super
smart
i like you're being responsible and
considering all the options
i'm trying to
sorry
just fall off just now
you